[Musique]
je m'appelle jean baptiste malvoisin je
suis actuellement coureur chez
technitoit dans les yvelines à
coignières j'ai 28 ans et je suis chez
technitoit depuis trois ans
[Musique]
notre activité consiste à la rénovation
de toitures donc ça peut être de
changement de clôture complète ou dans
la rénovation de remplacement des tuiles
isolation changement de gouttière mais
on fait également la rénovation des
toitures par le système de nettoyage de
démoussage et hydrofuge donc qu'ils
peuvent être notés sur de la tuque béton
pour nous la couverture c'est avant tout
un travail manuel sait qu'elle peut
compter 2 depuis longtemps on aime ça
rénover des belles maisons comme comme
celle ci c'est un travail en extérieur
on est assez libre
[Musique]
1 c ap en maçonnerie suivi d'un cep de
couvreur et j'ai prolongé ma formation
par un brevet professionnel des
couvertures pour ensuite être embauché
dans une entreprise comme couvreur
[Musique]
actuellement sur l' agence de coignières
on recherche une vingtaine de personnes
dix coureurs et 10 façadier à peu près
on recherche avant tout des décès des
ics
[Musique]
on cherche évidemment des gens avec de
l'expérience sachant que faire tout type
de couverture comme tous types de
façades des gens sérieux motivé avec
l'envi de l' envie d'apprendre rigoureux
avec un investissement personnel
[Musique]